UB OWE VERY MUCHFOD TO
PRESENTING OUR CASE  A JURY OF
CITIZENS IN THE SOUTHESTRICT OF.
>> SMITH DID N GO INTO DLS
OF THE INDICTMENT T SAID
TO READT.JOINING ME
ASSISTANY FOR E RNISK.
LET'S LK BICTURE.
FIRSOF ALL, HE'S INVESTIGATING
M
NOTH-A-LAGS ESSEY E FAAT THIS WN
LA J JANUARY 6tY
EN.HA Y SURFAE  AER
JAAR STILLOILS W ABOUT DUM
I DON'ERE'
ETS CHARGEBY
THD VENY PROGRE NOT SEENBOY CAS
NST TRUMP ONth.E.OULDN'T SURPE
GT I
DO YOU REA T
TRUMP IS GETTING AS  OF DOR R ST
THE INDICTMENT I
STRAIGHT FOR ANDDO.I THINENS CH.
CTHIS CASRRICD OVF  CHARGING J
MAY LOOKARAND THINATth
LAU BR RRICK ANE
PRIOERE, YOU AND I UT THE CON SB
PROSE
DET THAT SMITH
RA BMEWHWO THE
COMMENDATION.
S MERRICRIGHT?, ULTILY
W IS THECIAL
CO HOF THEO-DAY
SPL  A CER
POCTMENT OR A
NIN THATTORNEY GENETHAUTOMATIC
L WANTS.
W SMIT
RE IICKNOW TK GARLANAPICK GAR LE
OK AND WNOE
CALCULOUS.
COMMENTARYT PHS  PENING
CONTAINEHE INDICTMENBYHE
RA Y NE UP.
TO SE, IT,FF
PREAD OUT  T
E Y WITH WHICH HE WAS TREATING
THESE DOCUMENTS.UMPS'S RESPONSE
SPREAD
AND O UMP, ARE NEWSPAPER HEADLI.
WH T W
YOU KNOWHE WREFER.
I DO.
LL
INPHS INE  AGOUT
UNTHINKABLEW THEY ARE THERE A
.
HYT
ARE JU NEWSPAPERS.
T S S
INNOCUOUS OR S,OETHAT A SMALL W
DECIDEDLY NOT.
OULETHOS
>> JACK SMITH SATRIAL.G TO HAPPE
F SAY A
DEFENDANT IS ELETRIED WITHIN 7D.
KNOW H TNOT ACK SMITH WHEN THEO
TRIAL HASAING THAT ALL
RODAE
A A.M
FOR TRTOTIAT.
WIDES THE PP,  JUDGE, BU
ANIS THE WTU
MOTIONS, WITH
THE NEE,VESTIGATION.
THEOREFEE  IG
ACITH IS JT SAYINGWE'RE READY T
THAT'S AN IMPOE TO
SEND, BUT HE DOESN'T CONTR
.
ON MY CIVIL AIW  WHEE OF VENUE
FRIE P
BUT INSTEAD GOES TORID S BYIG
MOST OF THINK POLITICALLY 'SHOJS
OF
THREE  FOU A SHOCKER
C.TEAM WN E GRANRY L THEY WERE
YOU'RE R
MEWHO N IN THAJU
F S P WON FLORIDA IN0.
WON 40%DIFFERENT JURYL.SAY CT H
THGUY.DOBE IN
AN DOJIGGALLY.
ELR FLOR
AV THE BETTER
JURYL,THE THRIGHT THING.
THT WI